hello everyone
i'm utsunomiya from the pokemon company
in today's pokemon presents we will be
sharing information on several of our
games including the pokemon scarlet and
pokemon violet games
but before that
i'm happy to share some news about the
pokemon world championships that will be
held in london uk this year from august
18th to august 21st
please have a look at this video
hello pokemon trainers i'm chris brown
from the pokemon company international
and i'm delighted to share with you
updates on our annual pokemon world
championships
after three years our global community
will come together august 18th to 21st
in london for not only intense pokemon
battles but also to be together
celebrating old friendships and creating
new ones all in the spirit of friendly
competition we are expecting thousands
of players from around the world to
compete in this year's trading card game
video game and pokken tournament deluxe
events many players had long journeys
earning their invitation over several
years and we are thrilled to learn who
will earn the title of world champion in
2022
this year we are also adding many new
elements to the show beginning with two
new pokemon titles please join me in
welcoming pokemon go where nearly 100
players will compete across two age
divisions and pokemon unite where 16
teams from 11 regions will compete these
players have battled all year for their
shot to earn the title of the very first
world champion in these new categories
we also have a few surprises in store
for fans attending in person including
our largest ever pokemon center world's
pop-up shop for those unable to attend
in person you can follow all the action
from wherever you are on our dedicated
live streams for each product including
coverage of every championship match for
each age division pokemon tournaments
are held around the world and we hope
the competition at the world
championships inspire many new players
to make new friends through battling
and one more thing it's my honor to
unveil for fans today our new pokemon
world championships pikachu trophy take
a look
[Music]
thank you we look forward to seeing you
in london and now i would like to hand
it back to mr utsonomia
thank you very much mr brown
with the pokemon world championships
returning after three years
please look forward to exciting battles
to keep you on the edge of your seats
now i'd like to share some news about a
few of our games
for the first time in three years we
held in-person pokemon go fest events in
berlin and seattle and this weekend we
will be holding an event in sapporo
japan
mysterious creatures known as
ultrabeasts have appeared at each event
and these ultra beasts will all gather
together during the pokemon go fest 2022
finale event it will be held on august
27th the finale is a global event that
can be enjoyed by trainers wherever they
are in the world trainers will be able
to encounter pokemon they may not
normally see in the wild they can also
encounter the mythical pokemon shaymin
by completing special research
will you be able to help recontend with
the ultra beasts
and what has become of professor willow
who was sucked into ultra space through
an ultra wormhole stay tuned for the
story's conclusion
additionally daily adventure incense has
been added to the game it's a special
incense that can be used once a day and
lasts for 15 minutes it can attract
pokemon not normally seen in your area
and rumors say it might even attract
legendary pokemon
use daily adventure incense for a
15-minute adventure every day
over the past six years we've seen
pokemon from every region debut and
pokemon go there are now over 700
pokemon you can register to the pokedex
whether you're making new friends at
pokemon go fest or having heated battles
at the pokemon world championships the
entire world is the stage for pokemon go
and our adventures are just getting
started
pokemon unite the hot app for nintendo
switch and mobile devices
pokemon unite has continued to grow and
evolve since its release one year ago in
celebration of its first anniversary
we're adding not only new pokemon and
features to the game but also many
events and
campaigns a new type of quick battle
pika party will begin today august 3rd
in this special type of quick battle in
celebration of our first anniversary all
pokemon on the field both wild and
players are pikachu we hope you join in
the festivities
additionally buzzwole will be joining
unite battles starting today august 3rd
buzzwole is an all-rounder that can
grapple opposing pokemon and launch them
into the air
run amok in battle with buzzwol's
ability feast boost which temporarily
increases buzzwol's movement speed and
basic attack speed each time it knocks
out an opposing pokemon
this first anniversary is just the start
of what's to come in pokemon unite we're
planning more events for september as
well so please stay tuned
and we're gifting unite licenses in
hollow wear for pikachu lucario
blastoise snorlax and sylveon in
celebration of the first anniversary
hmm
[Music]
oh that makes sense
[Music]
[Music]
what's this looks like mewtwo's back in
the pokemon cafe remix game and it's
hungry
make delicious drinks and dishes with
your cafe staff to treat mewtwo to a
wonderful time once you make a lot of
delicious drinks and dishes and one
minute cooking to fill mewtwo up it can
join your staff
here are some hints on how to play the
one minute cooking puzzle mode to
satisfy mewtwo
tip one gather great staff
mewtwo likes to order small plates so
gather staff that specialize in small
plates pikachu squirtle the five-star
chef victini and the newly arrived
latias are good at those orders
if you want to aim for the high score
try raising your pokemon staff level go
to the pokemon menu to start raising
their staff level by training them once
your grade staff is up to the challenge
it's time to begin one minute cooking
on to the second tip just keep on mixing
as much as you can once you begin one
minute cooking keep on mixing the
pokemon to rack up those combos
use these tips to make delicious drinks
and dishes and you should be able to
satisfy mewtwo we hope you'll give one
minute cooking a try and there's more
following latias who just appeared today
latios will also appear in the future
wait there's even more we have a special
campaign underway starting today this is
your chance to get victini and latias on
your staff pokemon cafe remix is
available at no cost to start and is
playable on nintendo switch systems and
mobile devices
[Music]
next up an update on the pokemon scarlet
and pokemon violet games
[Music]
attention please
today we begin
[Music]
the treasure hunt
[Music]
travel across paldale
get to know the region
[Music]
the abundant nature
[Music]
the rich culture
the pokemon
[Music]
and the people
[Music]
where will you go
[Music]
who will you meet
[Music]
what will you achieve
[Music]
with you
will be your pokemon
journey together
learn together
[Music]
grow together
[Music]
find something to treasure
[Music]
so
[Music]
let the treasure hunt begin
we're now starting to get a clearer
picture of your adventures to come in
the paldea region
i'd like to dive a little deeper into
the information presented so let's take
a closer look together shall we
the newest titles in the pokemon series
are the pokemon scarlet and pokemon
violet games
these titles will be open world rpgs a
first for the pokemon series
sprawling landscapes and vibrant towns
weave together to form the paldeya
region where your new adventure will
unfold
[Music]
these are the legendary pokemon horidon
and miraidon you'll rely on one of them
as a partner in your adventure climb on
and together you'll dash across grassy
fields
move across water
and glide through the sky
your partner can change forms as needed
while you explore every nook and cranny
of the region with them
you will be enrolling at a certain
academy as a student
and a special independent study project
awaits you the treasure hunt through it
you'll embark on a journey to find
treasure of your own here in paldea
three grand stories are waiting for you
one story will revolve around the
familiar gym battles
you'll go to eight pokemon gyms and aim
for the champion rank
in these games there is no set path you
must take when challenging the gyms
chart your very own course along victory
road
the other two stories you'll experience
hold many surprises and discoveries as
well
which story will you begin with how will
you progress through them it is all up
to you
professor sada and professor churro
research legends passed on in the paldea
region mr clavell is the director of the
academy you'll attend
and mr jacques is your homeroom teacher
who teaches biology
you'll have your battle loving friend
nimona
[Music]
and you'll meet arvin an upperclassman
and a great cook
there's also penny a shy student in your
grade
there are gym leaders too
like grusha the ice type gym leader
the people you meet in paldea are sure
to enrich your adventures
[Music]
many different species of pokemon also
called the paldea region home
this pokemon is the paldayan regional
form of whooper
it lives on the land and covers its body
with a poisonous film
fido are delightfully squishy pokemon
that are smooth to the touch
and here's satitan which has a large
body and a hard horn that can freeze its
surroundings
of course we also have the pokemon from
which you'll choose your first partner
sprightito fue coco
and quaxley
enjoy meeting lots of pokemon
and complete your pokedex as part of
your adventure
by using the union circle you can enjoy
co-op play with up to three friends
you can go look for pokemon you haven't
yet discovered
or even ride together to race across the
map
enjoy all the paldea region has to offer
with family and friends
[Music]
the terrastil phenomenon makes pokemon
shine like gems
[Music]
[Applause]
all pokemon in the paldeya region are
able to terrastilize which can provide a
boost to a pokemon's type and make its
moves stronger
some pokemon will change type when they
terrastilize
what type they become seems to depend on
that pokemon's terra type
for example an eevee would typically
remain normal type after terrastilizing
but there could be ev that become grass
or water type after terrastilizing
we hope you'll try to catch pokemon with
rare terror types
pokemon that have rare terror types are
more likely to appear in terra raid
battles
you can challenge terra pokemon in these
battles with up to three other trainers
this is a new kind of raid battle where
you can attack or heal with your own
timing without having to wait for your
allies
try to cooperate with your allies to get
the upper hand in these battles
after you successfully defeat a tara
pokemon you'll get the opportunity to
catch it for yourself
[Music]
we've kept all the things you love about
pokemon while evolving the adventure you
can have in pokemon scarlet and pokemon
violet
we hope you look forward to the day you
set out on your adventure
the pokemon scarlet and pokemon violet
games are available to pre-order at
participating retailers now
[Music]
your independent study in the paldea
region begins in three months
we eagerly await your enrollment
that's all for today's presentation
thank you very much for tuning in and
watching
you